okay hi everyone welcome to another
episode of history of science and
technology q a
um and happy to answer questions uh
about things i've been involved in
myself or things that i might have
studied
in earlier history
we seem to have some questions
saved up
from
[Music]
the last time here
there's one from carop
with the benefit of hindsight what would
you have changed in the early
developments of the internet during the
late 60s early 70s if anything
you know i think the thing
first of all i should i'll tell a piece
of sort of personal history i mean i
started using the opennet
back was then the opennet back in 1976
um when there were i think 256
hosts on the arpanet each specified by a
number
um
it was uh it was kind of a fun time
because there were these somewhat
informal documents that existed i mean
the only places that had access
to the arpanet
were
various kinds of research and government
organizations
and i had access to it
well
when i was
after i left high school when i was 16
1976 and worked at a place called the
rutherford lab in england which is a
particle physics lab and they had access
to the arpanet and then i went to oxford
and there was an experimental physics
group there that had access to the
arpanet
um also was the only air-conditioned
room that i could find anywhere in um in
that part of the world at that time
and then
i think
i think i was spent a summer at argonne
national lab in the u.s and i think
that's where i first saw kind of a
directory of the arpanet of what were
all these hosts on the arpanet otherwise
you were just typing at o
you know 101 at 0.102 and you see
whether they produce a login prompt
um
and uh but any case that was sort of the
very early opennet then it became
possible to
dial up
to
to use a phone and an acoustic couple
modem for example to
just dial up an access point to the
arpanet
and that was certainly possible by the
time i was first in the u.s
first working in the us
in 1978.
so um and that was that was a time when
yeah there was the uh i was at caltech
at that time
and sort of the way to access the
arpanet that worked pretty well
was there was a thing called the federal
telecommunications system probably still
exists
fts that was kind of a way of making uh
kind of
long-distance phone calls on a different
phone network and you could kind of use
that phone network and then use an
acoustic coupled modem connect to
the uh
these dial-up things they were called
tips terminal interface processes i
think um and uh use and then use the
arpanet
okay so that was the very early history
of things
and
i would say that when
when by the time the web was coming out
in
1989 1990
um
these kinds of times i have to say that
that i was pretty
used to using
all kinds of well okay so email had been
a thing for for a while i mean i first
had an email address in 1976
um
and uh
email was something that was
particularly through uucp something i
think still exists the unix to unix copy
uh system a utility in the unix
operating system where it was like one
one computer calls on the phone another
computer which calls on the phone
another computer and that way your email
can get transferred from computer to
computer um that led to email addresses
that tended to have you know name exclam
name xclam which was kind of the path
that you would use to get to somebody
there was also a thing called bitnet
which was an ibm
sponsored thing i think that was
included a bunch of universities and so
there were addresses
through that too
but um
this whole idea of these there being
these various services that existed that
was sort of based on networks whether
they were networks that were just
through the phone system whether they
were actually sort of built in computer
networks like bitnet and so on and there
was one called nsfnet that was uh
another us government
network but um
by the time
i'm trying to remember uh
there were
a variety of systems there was a system
called gopher for example which was oh
yeah i should have explained ftp the
file transfer protocol
was a thing that was widely in use
before the web for example and it was
like you connect to a computer you can
still use it today still used for plenty
of things you um you connect to a
computer and you're just you know you're
using this ftp protocol uh which had
various commands and you could download
files and so on that became a little bit
more elaborate with this thing called
gopher which was a thing where i guess
like the animal or something it could um
could sort of hunt for things a bit on
the web
and then um my friend brewster kale
actually was involved in making this
thing called wastes
um what was that stand for probably wide
area
information service or some such other
thing which was another kind of
way of sort of getting resources on lots
of different computers
and meanwhile there have been these sort
of visions
of things like ted nelson's project
xanadu which was this kind of you know
hyper text everywhere sort of uh
everything was sort of a network
together all documents kind of had
networked pieces networked together and
so on that was kind of floating in the
background i don't think particularly uh
visible to people but i remember when
the web first
sort of came out i was like okay it's
another one of these things it's like
gopher it's like waste
it's useful but it's nothing special i
think the thing that really made the web
special in the end was when gifs
and images started to get
includable and when browsers uh started
to exist that could display those images
that's when things really took off when
i first saw the web i was like how could
it possibly work to have a system that
was a read-only deliverer of files
um my mistake
but you know my first thing was surely
people will want to have something where
you can
read and write the data not just
read the data
one of those things where i kind of
collect these places where i've made
sort of mistakes in
assessing what will take off and what
will not that's definitely one of them
and it's kind of interesting that so
many years later well there are two
things that that sort of surprised me
one was the the idea that um
it was sort of read-only the other was
the complete lack of any kind of
monetization layer
and you know at the time
the idea of well you're going to connect
to the web and you'll pay an internet
service provider and that's kind of the
monetization somehow but the original
providers of content on the web i just
figured that very soon there would be
some mechanism for micro payments or
something on the web and it just never
happened and it just it sort of was a i
think uh perhaps a thing that was
important to the history of the web that
that wasn't there at the beginning um
perhaps
in the long view of history it will be
like people will be very surprised it
wasn't there in the beginning
as people talk about kind of the whole
web 3 whatever that means and sort of
blockchain connected
uh webby type types of things the idea
of kind of a really smooth micro payment
structure infrastructure becomes a
little bit more plausible um but uh you
know that's one thing which i'm i'm
surprised it didn't develop
and of course that has it led to this
kind of complicated shell game of who's
paying and isps versus other things and
then the net neutrality issues and all
these kinds of things um but that's
something that uh uh just wasn't you
know tim berners-lee and other people
just didn't really talk about that at
the beginning because in a sense i mean
i i do have to tell the the footnote to
history story about the web
which was that uh back in 1987
um i made this deal with steve jobs and
his company next to get uh mathematica
bundled on the next computer and they
you know were paying us a certain amount
per computer to put a copy of
mathematica on every computer it was
kind of um
it's sort of an ms-dos like deal in some
sense i've just put the software on
every machine
so fine i i thought it was a good deal
and and it was it was a steve jobs
assessed the market correctly because
there were plenty of people who said
well i could buy uh
this kind of workstation computer or
whatever or i could buy next because if
i buy next i get mathematica for free
and you know that was that was his
calculation and it worked out
and one place that brought next
computers in order to get mathematica
for free was the theory division at cern
in geneva
uh european particle physics
organization
and uh they get these computers and i've
i'm you know they use mathematical on
them but i guess the person who was
managing that system sysadmin type
person was tim berners-lee and he
decided to do this experiment on these
network computers and that experiment
eventually became the web so that was
our little contribution as a sort of
micro footnote to history in the
development of of the web
but uh uh yeah so i think you know there
are other things about the sort of
construction of the web in the early
days of the web it seemed that there
would be all kinds of trouble with all
sorts of people talked about internet
storms and things of of traffic backing
up and there were there was the famous
story of the the router in hawaii which
uh you know the way the the way the
opponent was originally constructed and
the internet is constructed
um it's
it's intended to be very redundant it
was intended as a sort of safe military
kind of concept where even if you take
out a bunch of the computers the traffic
will still route around and get to its
destination well that all works just
fine until you have a situation like the
one that happened with this computer in
hawaii where it's you're trying to
assess what's the fastest route and the
computers are kind of reporting how long
it takes for data to go through those
computers and i guess this computer
reported a large negative amount of time
for how long it was taking for data to
go through that computer and so suddenly
you know all internet traffic started
getting routed through hawaii and
everything blocked up and it was all bad
and i think that the the structure of
kind of the whole routing world of the
internet has worked fairly well although
you know the few times i get into diving
into bgp routing tables and all this
kind of stuff uh it turns out it's
pretty hokey down there it's pretty much
a bunch of engineering solutions that
are you know it's it's great that it all
works
but when it doesn't work uh you know it
it's there are all kinds of issues but
the truth is it works and uh there's
enough communications capacity in the
world that it's one of these things that
ain't broke there's no real reason to
fix it but probably it could have been
done in a more principle way people
particularly people that understood how
how big the the internet was going to
become obviously things like the length
of ipv4 addresses and so on
which is not disastrous that you know
you'll you'll end up with these ipv6
addresses and the world is sort of
gradually transitioning to those things
that was something which i think was a
correct design decision at the beginning
of uh
don't you know there's no reason to to
over build the thing and not get
anything built just get something
working i mean other kinds of things
that worked better than one might have
thought the top level domain name
mechanism all the various mechanisms for
resolving kind of disputes about domain
names not perfect but could have been a
lot worse
and i think uh
uh
you know i i i would say that in general
it's one of these things which
uh was there had been sort of previous
efforts that was sort of pre-web that
didn't quite make it and the web just
had the right collection of things that
it was able to make it um and uh
you know i i i think one can one can
talk about
uh whether there are you know computer
security things that could have been
thought through better yes there
probably are but you're never going to
not learn those things until a billion
people are using the system uh were
there things that
could be done
to make the web more semantic so to
speak uh you know i think that that's a
trade-off again you can make things sort
of you can say there's a lot of
bureaucracy associated with setting up
your website and then you just reduce
the number of people who set up a
website and so again i think it's one of
these things where you set it up and
then you think about later is there a
way you can i mean i i tend to think
that the ultimately the web is a great
big data set of you know however many um
uh you know a few
what is it at this point it's a few
maybe 10 billion pages of interesting
information on the web it's surprisingly
small at some at some
some in some respects i mean if you go
for all sort of machine generated urls
it's trillions and trillions of urls but
if you go for actual a human made this
page it's more like the the five to ten
billion range i think
and um in that um
uh you know i i view the web as kind of
a big data set of what our civilization
has made and i have to say i think that
the kinds of things that have been done
with it as a data set are still rather
primitive i mean searching it is one
thing but there's a lot of other things
you can do with it and maybe one day
i'll i'll get to do them but um uh that
project keeps on getting um
tumbling down the priority list as
as things like figuring out things like
physics and figuring out things about
multi-computation and so on keep on
coming ahead of it
let's see
um
well let's see the question from aaron
what was my take in 1993 when the u.s
congress canceled the superconducting
supercollider project
uh what long-term effects did this have
so first of all just for people who
don't know the the
uh the superintendent super collider was
a big particle accelerator to be built
in texas
and uh well let's do a little bit of the
history of particle physics
so world war ii
manhattan project
nuclear physics
uh sort of big achievements there
um
after world war ii
the physicists had kind of elevated
themselves into kind of something where
both from a government point of view and
from a general public point of view
physics was an important thing
and on the tail of that kind of nuclear
physics effort
came well let's go look at subatomic
particles as they were called at that
time uh let's go look at um uh things
you know protons neutrons all these
particles that are in atomic nuclei and
uh all the all these pions exchanged
between protons neutrons and atomic
nuclei all these other kinds of
particles in the 1930s people had
started discovering these things in
cosmic rays where there are high energy
particles produced well around here
mostly from the sun um although there
are higher energy ones from from further
away but uh and then you just go on a
mountaintop where the atmosphere hasn't
absorbed most of those particles and you
have a like a stack of emulsion stack
like a stack of photographic film
basically and you would go and see the
tracks the particles ionizing particles
going through your your photographic
film and people have discovered the pion
the muon the lambda hyper on a bunch of
other particles have been discovered um
in the 30s and 40s in cosmic ray
experiments
but then
people wanted to get high energy
particles themselves
and sort of the most simple-minded way
to get such particles well a cathode ray
tube was accelerating electrons just by
using electrical uh uh
forces and um the uh
magnetic actually uh let's see the
no that's a pure electrical acceleration
method but but you can um uh the what
people had figured out was the thing
called the cyclotron was invented which
kind of came out of radar technology in
world war ii um in radar technology one
was making these
microwave cavities and one was having a
different radio
one was able to have intense radio
frequency
uh
electromagnetic radiation and one was
able to amplify it in things like
klystrons and so on and that you know
one branch of that world turned into
microwave ovens
the other branch of that world turned
into particle accelerators
and um
the and so after world war ii
uh development of particle accelerators
started off the cyclotron was the early
approach uh then the synchrotron um was
a different kind of technology that was
invented for accelerating particles and
that's pretty much the technology that's
used today
where particles there are two kinds of
accelerators circular accelerators and
linear accelerators circular
accelerators the particles go around in
a circle linear accelerators they go in
a straight line um the both kinds of
accelerators while the
the circular accelerator has the
advantage you get to give the particle a
kick every time it goes round the ring
but
on the other hand as it goes around the
ring you have to be continually
accelerating the particle to keep it
going around the circle
and for example if it's an electron it
will emit lots of synchrotron radiation
as it's being accelerated to keep going
around the circle
so you have to pump pump energy in just
to keep it going around the circle
whereas a linear accelerator you only
get one shot at accelerating the
particle but you don't have to keep it
going around in a circle
so anyway
in um
so what then happened was
that uh people started building particle
accelerators in the early 60s there were
the early particle accelerators they
started uh discovering just tons of
particles that led to a whole
development in particle physics that
eventually led to in one branch the of
the early development led to string
theory another part led to the quark
model a bunch of different pieces of
particle physics but basically lots of
particles getting discovered in 1960s
once people had sort of switched on
accelerators
and so then
so well
in the early days of these things there
were accelerators in lots of places
there were you know famous i in the mid
70s when i started getting involved in
particle physics
the well let's see the the kind of main
place in um
uh
in in europe with cern european center
for nuclear research said in french
um
that's why it's cern rather than spelled
the other way around um that had been
created what in the
mid 50s
as a
kind of a big example of collaboration
between governments
and um
in the words of a
director of cern
who was around at the time when the web
was invented and i was telling him you
know the web was invented at cern it was
like take this seriously it's really an
important thing and he was like
well but you know all these governments
have just put up this money for particle
physics we can't turn into a computing
place
um and part of the point of cern
was as an example of international
collaboration perhaps to some people
more so even than the science that was
going to be done there anyway it was
created in the 50s i think the um the
first machines um they had a
a small
um
the proton synchrotron ps and then that
became the sps the super proton
synchrotron and these were sort of
successively larger machines that were
built on site in geneva in the us
brookhaven national lab on long island i
think was the earliest well there was
lawrence berkeley lab was a place where
a lot of development
had been done on particle accelerators
but i think quite quickly brookhaven
became the place where the bigger
accelerators in the us were and then the
stanford linear accelerator center which
was a linear accelerator of electrons um
if you drive on the what is it the two
oh my gosh what is it the 101 the
freeway 210 freeways all right that's
parallel to the 101 freeway in um uh in
silicon valley you cross over the um the
stamford lunar accelerator um you can
see that
the the the straight line that goes for
i don't know a mile or two um that is
the the particle accelerator there um
that was that was built
and uh a thing that happened
in um and so there were accelerators all
over the place there were some in in
russia
there were some in italy were notable
ones there were ones in germany japan
i'm trying to remember all the different
ones
but all of these different places were
getting accelerators that you can kind
of measure the
the the these accelerators were in the
gev range a few gev
um and uh that's a few um uh billion
electron volts that's kind of the um
it's the equivalent in pure energy of
the rest mass of a proton would be one
gev
and so these were in the you know four
gev things like this kind of kind of
range
and um getting up to maybe um uh well
what really matters this is sort of
relativity fact
is um if you have a okay so what really
matters is the center of mass energy if
you have two particles that are
colliding what matters is if you were to
be at rest in the center of mass of
those two particles what will be the
total energy of those particles that's
what matters if you uh collide a
particle with a fixed target
the center of mass
is is the
it's it's such that it's the square root
of the energy is what matters
what determines the center of mass
energy for a particle colliding with a
fixed target so if you could only get
two particles going sort of in opposite
directions it's a hugely higher center
of mass energy and the center of mass
energy is the amount of energy that
determines for example how particle
production and generally sort of the the
particle physics uh uh excitement of the
whole thing is determined by the amount
of energy in the center of mass
so then the thing that was invented were
colliding beam machines
they were invented in
well they were existing there were a few
by the mid 1970s
um and uh there were
sort of in order to have so that for
example um if you have a colliding beam
machine where protons are colliding with
protons you have to have two separate
rings
um obviously a colliding beam machine in
the in the usual way it's set up is a
circular machine although people have
proposed colliding beam machines linear
colliding beam machines
um but uh the uh usually circular and
when you have protons for example you
have to have two rings because whatever
the magnetic field does to one proton
it's going to make it go this way and
the other proton if you want to go in
the opposite direction you have to have
an opposite magnetic field to get it to
go in the opposite direction
well then somebody had the bright idea
what if we run anti-particles in the
same ring in the same uh because they
have the opposite charge they'll go with
the same magnets they'll go in the
opposite direction
so that was first done with electrons
and positrons and that was a thing
happening in the in the 70s
um
and uh there was a version of that at
stanford there was a version of that in
italy i remember and there may have been
some versions of other places as well
um the uh there were a bunch of big
discoveries made
in the uh well i i should say that all
these particle accelerators they'd all
vibe to make all sorts of different
discoveries um the for example the omega
minus particle which was discovered in
the
early 60s was discovered at brookhaven
national lab and that was sort of the
thing that that clinched the quark model
um uh idea then another big discovery
was the discovery that there were sort
of hard bits inside protons the part on
model another story of quarks that was
done at the stanford linear accelerator
center around 1970 or so
um then
there was a sort of big discovery in
1974
the j psi particle it was called the j
particle when it was discovered a
brookhaven
um in their
proton accelerator and it was called the
psi particle was discovered at in
stanford at the in the um uh
uh electron accelerator that was there
but any case the the big thing and by
the way that was an interesting case
because it was discovered both
in um
uh
a fixed target accelerator where protons
were crashing into a fixed block of lead
or something and in a colliding beam
accelerator where uh electrons and
positrons were were colliding with each
other in the same ring but going in
opposite directions because their
charges are opposite now what people
really wanted to do is to make a proton
antiproton machine
the reason electrons aren't so great is
that i mentioned before electrons emit
synchrotron radiation and so basically
there's this general rule in
that an accelerated charge will emit
radiation
that's a general kind of principle of
electromagnetism although the details of
how that works are a bit complicated and
there's a whole sort of complicated
story of exactly exactly how that works
but but in any case the
that's why for example there is
synchronous radiation emitted in lots of
astrophysical settings when electrons
are being accelerated
in magnetic fields of various kinds of
systems
and that also happens you know here on
earth if you have a high energy electron
and you're making it go around this ring
it will emit synchrotron radiation which
is bad because then it loses energy and
you have to pump more energy into it
so in any case protons
have much less tendency to emit
synchrotron radiation it depends on the
mass and protons are 1800 times more
massive than electrons
so
there was a big win to be able to do
that the only problem was you needed a
big stream of anti-protons where'd you
get a big stream of anti-protons well if
you crash protons into a target
some of the things that will come out
will be proton antiproton pairs if at
least if the protons have enough energy
you have to collect the antiprotons you
can do that by having essentially a mass
spectrometer you have have the the the
protons going a certain speed you have a
certain magnetic field you know that
they'll be deflected uh
an amount that depends on their mass and
so on so you can kind of separate off
the antiprotons the problem then is that
the antiprotons when they were produced
were going in all kinds of different
directions if you want them to keep
going around this ring
uh zillions of times you have to make
sure all the antiprotons are going in
exactly the same direction and so there
was a bunch of technology i think
originally developed at cern for
anti-proton cooling to make it possible
to make a beam of anti-protons and so in
that was kind of the the next big thing
was to make uh colliding beam machines
with proton anti-proton colliding beam
machines and that's what
cern has had a series of accelerators
the most recent is the lhc the large
hadron collider
which is a a proton antiproton colliding
beam machine
the um
okay so in the u.s
the other uh thing that sort of came
online was fermilab uh in um batavia
illinois near chicago
um and it had sort of the biggest uh
accelerator
in um uh
um
in the u.s
and um let's see when did it come online
well it was certainly um
the they were certainly operating by
1977
because
i visited there a bunch then
and it was in full operation and it was
a it was a place the uh chap called
robert wilson had been the sort of
creator of fermilab and it was um it had
an interesting kind of approach
to um
having to being a a sort of a visible
science thing where you know usually
when you have a magnet you just have a
thing that's you know that's that's
metal colored but um uh
robert wilson had the magnets painted
bright colors so things looked much more
kind of spiffy and the main building at
fermilab had this kind of fine shape i'm
not sure it's aged that well but it had
a it had a fine kind of swoosh type
shape um that was kind of dramatic
and
a bunch of things were done that kind of
made it
a um a very nice piece of kind of uh
science
intended for presentation so to speak um
as well as science just intended for the
doing of science i do remember that um
they uh in the main on in in the ring
they had a sort of a nature preserve and
they kept uh what were they buffalo i
guess in the in the ring at fermilab and
i have to say the the um i was at a
conference there in 1979 um and uh it's
kind of a it's let's just say it's it's
banquet had an interaction with that it
was i think the last time that was done
um the uh
but um
in any case the so fermilab had been the
big um
uh particle accelerator in the us and at
that point by it was sort of fermi lab
and stanford lunar accelerator center
was sort of another piece and fermi lab
had kind of built up another level of of
um the particle accelerator i guess it
was called the tevatron they reached a
trillion electron volts in the center of
mass a colliding beam machine
that was a
that was a proton anti-proton colliding
beam machine as i recall
um
but and sort of the the holy grail of
particle physics at the time
had been
let's see if the standard model of
particle physics is right let's discover
the w particle let's discover the z
particle
um those were duly discovered
um
in when were they discovered they were
that must have been in the 80s um
and uh you know the thing that was a
little bit embarrassing is that there
were had been things about well
so-called neutral current weak
interactions which is what the z
particle is all about there had been
things
that if only the theory had been there
in the early 1960s people would have
noticed them at that time there were
experiments done at cern in the early
60s that absolutely will have seen
so-called neutral current interactions
involving neutrinos
and uh
unfortunately by the time the theory
existed people had thrown away
the the the bubble chamber film this is
one of those if you do experiments that
cost millions of dollars keep all the
data stories um but they had they hadn't
kept the data they had thrown away that
that film and so when the theory came
around nobody could go back and just
look and see oh how did that work um
in any case the super collider
so
what happened
was that it was sort of what was the
next step beyond the tevetron at
fermilab and so on what was the next
step for u.s particle physics i think
there have been a sort of a long time
when particle physics had been kind of
the the payback to the physics community
for the manhattan project and by this
point this was now
uh must have been the 90s 1990s um sort
of the there was a you know the
generational shifts that happened and a
lot of the people who were sort of early
particle physics people in the us when i
was working in particle physics in the
70s for example
a lot of most of the older people have
been somehow involved with the manhattan
project or whatever else
and
it was very much it felt like this was
sort of an extension of the manhattan
project story and by the 90s that sort
of been generational changes and that
was no longer so much the case
well
the thing that happened um
was uh
the um
then
uh there was okay the us needs to build
another bigger bigger stronger particle
accelerator and so there was a huge
effort i knew all kinds of people who
were involved in site selection for
where's this thing going to get built is
it going to be built in arizona is it
going to be built in this place is going
to be built in that place
and you know a lot of the ways that
going to be built is who is going to get
the sort of the the the civil
engineering
kind of um
uh
uh
sort of there was a big it's a big civil
engineering project to build a big
tunnel and then there's lots of
engineering uh and so on and it's sort
of you know it's it's a it's a thing of
of uh sort of local political relevance
um who gets to actually have that in
their state
i have to say i'm i'm i'm not sure that
particle physics
or physics
facilities are the biggest generators of
local economic
activity um i i'm reminded many years
ago i this must have been oh gosh when
was this this must have been mid-1980s
and so my information is is deeply out
of date but i happened to um
visit the uh um
uh vla the very large array radio
telescope in socorro new mexico
and um uh just as a as a tourist um kind
of thing
and um it's it's in a very remote spot
because that's a good thing if you if
you have a radio telescope um you
definitely don't want
lots of random radio noise around there
i think in green bank west virginia
there's a sort of a cell phone free town
for the radio telescope that's uh sort
of uh supporting the radio telescope
that's there
but anyway back in back in those days it
was a remote area and i remember driving
through this town
uh getting towards the the radio
telescope and this town
had this um uh was it i think been a
mining town probably in the 1800s and it
had been you know it had its boom and
then it's bust and become a ghost town
and then i think it had one more lease
of life after that and then it had and
then the radio telescope came
and this this town had this kind of
signage up this sort of wooden sign up
about how oh we were once a ghost town
but now thanks to the radio telescope we
are a thriving town again
sadly that sign was on a sort of rotting
piece of wood and behind it were was
kind of a a a ghost town
so so the radio telescope didn't at
least at that time i don't know what's
happened since then in the you know many
years since then it may have been now an
absolutely thriving uh community and i i
am
mean it no ill by by
relating it's it's history but um uh in
any case for me it was sort of a an
interesting story of of uh of what did
or did not come about from from that
kind of economic development but anyway
so the supercollider early 1990s uh
physicists vying for
uh where would the um uh you know where
would the thing be would it be in texas
would it be in arizona would it be in
this place or that place now there are
places that are better and worse there
are places that have higher earthquake
risk it's pretty bad if you have a big
particle accelerator and it's all
perfectly lined up and you've got all
your magnets set up and then there's an
earthquake that's bad now of course you
know they're things where it's even
worse if the if the earth shifts like
the gravitational wave detectors which
are built in louisiana and in washington
state
um i know that the the one in louisiana
i happened to visit there a few years
ago um and uh it's one of these places
where it says you know don't stamp your
feet around here you know you know be
quiet
it's um because otherwise you'll you'll
generate noise for the gravitational
wave detector but uh apparently they you
know there's a lot of noise there from
the um um
from the gulf of mexico from waves
crashing on the shore there's noise from
logging
in different places and it was
kind of only a so-so place to locate a
gravitational wave detector i'm told
there's sort of a question of where's
the least seismic activity in the world
and i think one thing you want is to be
far away from
from all oceans and things i believe
there's some spots in kazakhstan that
are sort of the the most seismically
inactive parts of the world um and i
don't know in the us what the most
seismically inactive area in in the
country is but any case so that was an
issue there were all kinds of sort of
physical issues in the site selection
for the uh for the super collider and
then there were political issues and in
the end sort of texas won the
uh the competition there
and but then
uh and you know it was all sort of
chugging forward and so on
and then what happened was the particle
the physics community
it had been the case that sort of in the
runoff from the manhattan project
particle physics had been the winning
area of physics
and it was sort of the the hottest uh
coolest whatever
adjective you used to describe it area
and sort of there was also solid state
physics as it was called the study of
electrons and materials the study of the
structure of solids all this kind of
thing
and uh my sometime friend murray gilman
inventor of quarks
used to unkindly refer to that area of
physics as squalid state physics one of
the many things he did to make friends
with people but any case so you know the
particle physicists thought they were in
charge they were the solid state
physicists that field sort of later
renamed itself condensed metaphysics to
cover liquids and things as well um and
other more exotic forms of matter but um
uh
so in
as we get in towards the 90s you know
particle physics have been absolutely
the top field of physics cadets
metaphysics was kind of climbing rapidly
and
this supercollider was going to be this
big sort of particle physics thing
so what happened well sort of knives
were drawn i i wasn't in the business at
the time i was
building that was the early years of
well
by that time i was working on
my new kind of science project as well
as
uh mathematica had come out in 1988 and
so on in any case the thing that um uh
the the sort of the two people who kind
of most
uh uh you know crossed swords on this
were probably steve weinberg and phil
anderson and i just realized recently
that when my new kind of science book
came out the two most pitchforky reviews
of the book were from none other than
steve weinberg and phil anderson who
themselves were were in you know locked
in mortal kombat over over sort of the
future of physics and so i think it's
kind of interesting that um they both
said no no no it can't possibly be the
stuff that's in this you know in my new
kind of science book even as they were
saying to each other it can't possibly
be the thing the other one of you is is
saying it is
um i think it's sort of uh uh they both
died actually steve weinberg died this
this last year and phil anderson
shortly before that um and uh um
so the our physics project i'm afraid
gives a bit of a
uh a bit of a lie to the things that
they had to say back 20 years ago when
my new kind of science book came out um
but you know
consider it a cautionary tale
when one is um you know once worked in a
field for a long time and something new
comes along and um it's pretty hard to
say oh there's this new thing is
interesting it's it's kind of um uh
i i view it for myself as sort of a
cautionary tale so i've seen these kinds
of kinds of mistakes that get made but
any case back in the early 90s there
were
uh you know steve weinberg for particle
physics
um phil anderson for condensed
metaphysics and they started attacking
each other like crazy and and the whole
community sort of attacked each other
like crazy and in fact this was a time
when i was kind of a hermit working on
my science project um living in the
chicago area
and uh the um a number of physicists
reached out to me and sort of said what
should we do you know can we can we keep
the supercal islander alive what should
we actually do and so i said well look
here's an exercise
you know
imagine you're going to take a full-page
ad in the new york times and you're
going to make the case for the super
collider you've got one ad that's it
what are you going to say and i was kind
of remembering steve jobs's move in 1984
when when no no 19 earlier than that 82
or something when when ibm
brought out the pc
you know he
he ran this ad you know this full-page
ad which said you know welcome ibm comma
seriously
uh kind of reflecting on the fact that
ibm entering the personal computer
market space
was essentially validating what apple
had already been doing there and um uh
in any case that was a it was sort of a
dramatic ad and people remember you know
i it's it's a memorable ad that people
remembered for a long time afterwards
and so my statement to the particle
physicist was that's what you've got to
do and i was also remembering a
statement that robert wilson made in
connection with fermilab when somebody
in some
congressional situation um asked him you
know how does fermilab contribute to the
defense of the united states
and his response was
well it's it's part of what makes the
united states worth defending
and um so it was kind of another one of
these quite quite you know quite
memorable quotes and so i was
encouraging the particle physicists to
you know
figure out what your best shot is and
take it you know why should the us be
spending you know 10 billion or whatever
it was going to end up being
on um
on this particle accelerator what was
what's the point
is it for
kind of human resource developments of
let's keep some physicists warm in case
we have another manhattan project
is it for technological spin-off that's
probably far in the future
is it to say look we've got one of these
particle accelerators and you over there
on the other side of the world you don't
have one of these we're superior you
know what's the reason for it is it uh
or is it you know
the basic science is a complicated thing
to justify in um uh but in any case the
the question was what could the
physicists say that was going to be the
pithy
this is the story of of why
why the country should spend 10 billion
dollars on us
well they couldn't figure out anything
to say
and um i remember
the um
uh actually i was coming back to me i i
remember
shortly before probably right before the
final vote that killed the super
collider i was at a dinner at fermilab
um and i was sitting across the table
from leon letterman who was then the
director of fermilab
and
i spent the whole dinner basically
saying to leon over and over again in
all kinds of different ways you know in
this vote that's going to happen if it
goes
the way you don't want it to go and the
super collider is killed what are you
going to say
because whatever you say you have an
opportunity a moment
when there's a chance people remember
what you say and if you say more or less
oh it's so sad that they took our toys
away or whatever
nobody's going to care but if you have
some really
clear statement about the importance of
basic science to the u.s or whatever
else it is
that has a chance to kind of break
through the noise well
i didn't persuade him to to come up with
a great quote i think i suggested a
whole bunch of possibilities um as it
was when the super collider was
cancelled it really didn't look very
good for the particle physics community
it was kind of more of a well you know i
don't know what happened and you know it
shouldn't have happened and oh well
whatever
um
it didn't seem like there was no sort of
clear story there now you know there's
a
uh
to me this whole question of you know
build a bigger accelerator that's the
way to do physics the thing that people
were still holding out for there was
discovering the higgs particle which was
sort of the last piece in the in the
standard model story that might be
accessible to present-day accelerators
and of course there's always the
unexpected but pretty much particle
physics since the late 70s hasn't
discovered anything really unexpected um
a little bit neutrino masses are a
little bit a little bit like that but
most of it has been we knew the set of
quarks we knew the set of leptons um and
we had expectations from the standard
model about what would be there and by
golly it's actually there and that's
what accelerators have discovered so
it's a little bit of a hard sell because
you've got to say well let's you know we
have to expect the unexpected so to
speak but there hasn't been any any
unexpected and the next place where we
know there'll be new stuff going on is
far out of range of current accelerators
now i have to say that a thing that i
personally have pushed a bit
is uh the concept that well you know the
same methods of accelerating particles
have been being used
for 70 years now and um it's like
one of the issues is in a typical
particle accelerator you're accelerating
you know 10 trillion particles at a time
and you get those 10 trillion particles
to be at a certain energy crash into
other particles crashing targets things
like that
but in fact what really matters is
those if if you could get
let's say a million particles
accelerated to a million times the
energy that they have right now that
will be very
interesting because there'll be a bunch
of phenomena they're a bunch of
phenomena that can only occur if the
particles have a certain energy but
basically the point is that when you are
going to produce a particle
anti-particle pair you need a sufficient
energy that corresponds to the rest
masses of those particles to be able to
produce that pair so if you have that
energy you will be able to produce those
particles if you don't have that energy
no dice you'll never be able to do it
the only way you'll be able to get any
evidence of those particles is through
sort of virtual effects of those
particles but that's a much more subtle
thing but actually just producing them
and being able to see them in a detector
and so on for that you just need the
energy to be able to do it and so the
question is are there completely
different ways to accelerate particles
people talk about they'd be talking
since i was got involved in particle
physics in the mid 70s they've been
talking about laser sort of getting
particles to ride sort of waves of of uh
kind of laser uh type acceleration um
what is it electromagnetic wake field
acceleration is that right i've
forgotten the um uh
but you know that's a that's a question
as far as i'm concerned is is it obvious
that building these particular giant
uh particle accelerators is going to be
the right answer
and uh is it in fact the case i mean as
we look at our physics project it's a
very interesting question uh if one was
going to say okay let's go test this
project um you know what's the right
thing to do what does one have to have
my guess is that when we've done sort of
the intervening layers of physics it
will be one of these situations that i
hope doesn't play out like the cern
neutral current story it'll be one of
these things where it's like there's an
effect that should have been seen if
anybody had looked for it in this place
now just go look for it in data that
already exists my guess is that there'll
be a bunch of those before there are
even or maybe maybe there'll also be
ones where it's like build a new build a
new experiment that can do this but i
think there'll be ones where one can go
back and look at things that have
already been observed and see whether
they work out in the way that we expect
now that was perhaps
bizarrely different and completely
unexpected from existing physics
theories
but you know in terms of of the effect
of the killing of the super collider on
on physics in the us i think one of the
things that definitely happened was the
ascendancy of condensed metaphysics and
you know particle physics was very much
a sort of a string theory story and that
was a pretty much a theoretical story
that was far away from experiment
because there weren't really experiments
that could be done and people kind of
helped it that they might relate to sort
of finding experimental implications and
new particles and things but that didn't
pan out
um and so particle physics was in a
fairly theoretical phase the
intersection of particle physics was
cosmology and astrophysics was more
energetic uh quite literally so in terms
of the particles being detected and so
on and uh you know all kinds of
neutrino detectors and other things and
and sort of fancy stuff at the south
pole and all kinds of things like this
that was quite energetic
meanwhile condensed metaphysics kind of
came up in energy
a lot
and became sort of a
perhaps even a dominant part of physics
and i think that's pretty much segued
into things where under the brand of
quantum computing now is a whole
condensed matter physics story that
maybe isn't training some particle
physicists as well so that's sort of a
combined thing perhaps but i would say
that the um
one could ask the question
what's been the difference between
the us's story in terms of physics and
let's say europe where there's cern is
operating um there have been
uh
there have been some facilities in other
places that have been operating i think
there's even in the us there's one at
cornell there's in japan there's one i
i um
i don't follow the the i used to if
you'd asked me um 40 years ago about
particle accelerators i would have been
able to tell you every particle
accelerator every experiment being done
in every particle accelerator
all those kinds of things but i'm afraid
i'm i'm out of touch on that on that
stuff
but uh uh they've
you know there's there's a question of
is there sort of a center of activity
um
that these particle physics um
facilities have generated
and i would say i i don't don't know for
sure i mean if you look at you know i
know hamburg germany has one and um you
know the particular places that have
them and i don't know whether there's
been whether one could say there's been
a big sort of national scale
uh kind of uplifting of physics
in countries that have big particle
acceleration i'm not sure how good a
correlation there is with those things i
think when it comes to particle
accelerators and does the technology of
particle accelerators contribute to
other kinds of things uh the answer is
well for example there are medical
applications of accelerated particle
beams
um one thing is that when you have these
more exotic kinds of beams they have of
chaons and pions and lambda particles
and things like that they have different
characteristics in terms of when they go
into a
piece of tissue there's a question of do
do the particles kind of you know when
they go in do they just keep going
without losing much energy and then
suddenly at some depth you know one
centimeter in do they suddenly deposit
all their energy or do they gradually
deposit their energy in this long line
and if you're trying to do cancer
therapy for example the typical thing
you want is to go to a certain depth
without harming the tissues that you're
going through and then kind of uh
deposit all your energy right there you
know to to kill off the tumor but um so
there are definitely things that get
done with with particle beams for those
kinds of things although the the
detailed design of uh the accelerator
physicists who worked on designing
things like fermilab are you know the
critical people in terms of
of designing those kinds of medical uh
accelerators but the the the detailed
the engineering considerations are a bit
different from the ones for particle
physics
so that's kind of the um uh
um
uh this is um
uh
yeah that that that that's that's that
story
well let's see
um
gosh lots of questions here sorry it
went on for
for a while um
okay gologaz says
um they recall lord kelvin famously
saying
that uh sort of actually i don't know
whether kelvin said this government was
involved in in several of these
statements but around 1900
people saying i think it was a
commissioner of patents who said you
know everything that's going to be
invented has been invented and uh you
know physicists saying everything that's
going to be discovered has been
discovered
um always a very dangerous claim to make
um i think that uh
in um
um
you know
commenting that was just before special
relativity you
know it's interesting i think
there's a question of when there are
unexplained phenomena
or unexplained reasons for knowing
phenomena
um
you know
when does that indicate there's
something big going on
and when doesn't it
and i think
in
and
how much unexplained stuff so for for
example in physics
there are there are on a theoretical
side there are issues about you know
sort of how does gravity fit in to
theories of particle physics
on the experimental side there's things
like where's the dark matter in the
universe where's the dark energy those
kinds of things um there are there are
those kinds of things hanging out there
that are like something is incomplete in
our current model of physics
i think
that
there is probably even more that one
should have said was sort of incomplete
in physics
the
it's just like well we have relativity
but we don't really know why we have
relatively we have quantum accounts we
don't really know why we have quantum
mechanics
you know our
model of fundamental physics
actually gives an answer to those things
i didn't think there would be an answer
that we would know in the next hundred
years actually um this is all very much
ahead of what i thought would be
possible
um i think that
uh that's something one kind of just
didn't see coming
i i think for example the stuff i've
been doing very recently on
metamathematics
is kind of following up on things that
were done 120 years ago or so now and
thinking about kind of how one imagines
mathematics as an abstract field how one
says sort of mathematics is really the
study of formal axiom systems and their
consequences
and sort of
what that sort of the fundamental theory
of mathematics has been you start from
things like the axioms of set theory and
then you build up all of these different
features of of mathematics
uh the thing that i absolutely didn't
see coming
is i we now have a a different model of
meta mathematics a physicalized model of
metamathematics that tells you very
different things about the foundations
of mathematics
that sort of come out of these ideas of
this thing i call ruliad which is this
thing that's sort of a
a necessary foundational structure that
lies underneath both physics and
mathematics
i didn't see this coming if somebody had
said will there be a general theory of
meta-mathematics i would have said i
don't i don't know i don't think so but
i never really thought about it
until
uh the things that i've been doing in
the last six months or so as a
consequence of our physics project
so that's a thing where there's a
there's a big thing hanging out there i
think but it is something that you
couldn't it wasn't like there was a big
phenomenon that we didn't understand
there is a phenomenon in mathematics
that we haven't understood which should
have been a clue and i have to say i saw
this clue and i probably took it in the
wrong direction and the clue is that
undecidability as discovered by kurt
godel and so on 1931
is not something that your average
mathematician worries about every day
and why is that why is it that most of
the mathematics that people do avoids
undecidability that's kind of a clue
that there's something fishy going on
there's something more to the story it's
kind of like saying
you know most of the mass in the
universe is not accounted for it must be
dark matter type thing there's something
else going on
so
there are things like that
i think that um uh probably in the early
1900s
the thing or late 1800s
one of the things that should have been
more obvious as a thing where gosh that
one there should be more to say is what
led to quantum mechanics things about
atoms atomic spectra things about
chemistry chemical bonds things like
this
there should have been i think in
retrospect it should have been more
obvious that there was a big other thing
out there than perhaps it was and and
maybe you know usually what happens in
science is sciences define themselves to
be about the things where the
methodology of that science has
something to say
which is not necessarily the same thing
as being about some particular domain of
of uh of stuff it's about where the
methodology works
and i don't really know that history
that well of of what people
said i mean there were sort of mysteries
about atomic spectra why are atomic
spectra the way they are we don't really
know etc etc etc i mean the final
mystery that led max planck to invent
quantum theory in 1900 was a pretty
detailed thing
about
the black body radiation when you have a
a black
box which is you know just black
absorbing box and you heat it up to a
certain temperature
then there will be radiation
electromagnetic radiation eventually if
you heat it up hot enough it'll get you
know red hot white art etc you'll see
visible light but there's a certain
spectrum to that radiation
and what planck noticed
is that there'd been sort of a standard
way of deriving that spectrum but it
didn't really work anymore
and when with the new experiments that
have been done and plank realized that
if if in fact
electromagnetic radiation came in quanta
in discrete quantized pieces
then you could fit the data and you
could in a way that you couldn't fit the
data otherwise and einstein came along a
little bit later and kind of clarified
through things like photoelectric effect
and and other things kind of a little
bit more what it meant for
electromagnetic radiation to exist in
sort of a quantized particle-like form
of photons in that case
but i think sort of the the early
signs of quantum mechanics
probably should have been more obvious
than relativity
and relativity the discovery of that was
really a story of sort of aesthetics of
of theoretical aesthetics more so than
oh we've got an experiment we don't
understand
now i think that um
uh why did quantum mechanics even get
discovered at the time i did i'm not
sure
i have this kind of proto hypothesis
which i really haven't checked out with
the properly with the history of science
that had to do with the invention of
electronic amplifiers
and that that what had been done you
know people had discovered things in
biology from being able to use
microscopes they discovered things in
astronomy from being able to use
telescopes but the ability to amplify a
small signal which is a capability that
existed that had come into existence
primarily through amplifiers being
invented for radio the ability to do
this amplification of small signals
maybe was the thing that sort of made
possible the sort of systematic
discovery of phenomena that would lead
to quantum mechanics and maybe those
hadn't been as obvious before the last
decade or two of the
the of the 1800s um because that
technology had not existed
but i think in today's world
there are well there are all kinds of
things i mean i could start reeling off
rattling off a bunch of bunch of things
where uh
you know
again it's always a question of what
matters and what doesn't like for
example it was known the advance of the
perihelion and mercury the the orbit of
mercury processes slightly the ellipse
that is the orbit of mercury around the
sun the ellipses and oreo always
oriented the same way it processes a
small amount and that's not something
you can get with a standard inverse
square law of gravity and so that was a
mystery but you know it could have been
a mystery that was to do with the shape
of the sun and the way that it's the way
that it produced this inverse square law
and so on and eventually that mystery
was cleared up by general relativity but
that was an example of something where
you know you could have said there's a
big mystery here let's go you know let's
go build a giant theory but i don't
think that would have been probably the
right thing to do
uh in terms of special relativity there
really wasn't
an experimental mystery it was a
theoretical mystery the theoretical
mystery was that maxwell's equations for
electromagnetism from the 1870s 1880s um
were had this feature that they applied
implied the speed of light was constant
but
the
the um when you thought about mechanical
processes the sort of classic thing is
the thought experiment of you take a
flashlight you run at 90 percent of the
speed of light does the light come out
of your flashlight at 1.9 times the
speed of light or does it come out only
at the standard speed of light in order
to get it to come out only at the
standard speed of light you have to
change your view of space and time and
that's what einstein did in special
relativity was to reconcile the fact
that the speed of light is constant with
the fact that even if you run fast
light isn't going to come out of your
flashlight any faster so to speak
and so but that was very much of a
theoretical almost philosophical
observation
i would say
actually i would consider it in some
ways a bit
in some ways our physics project is also
something that was born out of sort of a
a philosophical abstract
uh kind of desire to bring together
certain theoretical uh kind of
uh features and frankly uh an almost
aesthetic notion of you know so okay how
are we going to what are we going to
make this universe of ours out of
um more so than there's this experiment
go explain this experiment kind of thing
now there are other fields i mean i
happened one that i suspect
i i should explain that that i view
a sort of big outgrowth of our physics
project as being what i'm sort of
referring to as the fourth paradigm for
making models in science
um i think i mentioned this before but
the way i see it is there's sort of been
four periods of making scientific models
from antiquity it was all about what are
things made of this kind of structural
paradigm of are things made of atoms are
things made of epicycles and so on no
particular notion of dynamics and time
just what are things made of
then the 1600s the kind of mathematical
paradigm
was kind of let's write down an equation
that describes how things work
time in that case becomes a parameter in
the equation you can turn the knob get
to whatever time you want
then we get to the 1980s and
to some extent my own efforts
in sort of making computation based
models of things and saying use programs
not equations to make models of things
one feature of that is time now has a
different character
because you say you you set up these
rules for this program and then you let
it run and it goes crunch crunch crunch
running the computation and there is
something sort of irreducibly happening
in the process of that computation it's
not something we just turn a knob and
say what's going to happen a million
steps from now it's something where you
have to sort of irreducibly run the
computation this is this concept of
computational irreducibility of mine and
um the uh so that's kind of the sort of
the third paradigm is this kind of
computational paradigm and i i would say
i take some uh pride in the fact that
having you know i started talking about
this in the 80s and i wrote this big
book in 2002 about kind of how to think
about this new kind of science as i as i
called and i i have to say i've been
very amused that that uh you know at the
time when i put that book out people are
saying how can you call this a new kind
of science etc etc etc and um i've had
several conversations recently with
people where they're sort of where we're
talking about the way science is going
and and the contributions of various
things i've i've been involved in and so
on and the person's like well the thing
you created is is you know it's kind of
like a new kind of science and then they
think oh my gosh that's actually what
you called the book
and
it's like yeah yeah well yes that was
the point type thing but um in any case
the the uh you know what happened um
in uh
uh
from sort of the early days in the 1980s
and then to 20 years ago
uh and and after that
was this sort of second paradigm of
mathematical equations which have been
the dominant paradigm for 300 years in
kind of exact science
i would say definitely kind of gave way
for new models that were being made to
this kind of third paradigm of of
computation
and so now
the thing that the physics project has
shown us is that there's actually a
fourth paradigm which is not just this
idea of computation where you are sort
of say i've got this rule i'm going to
run the rule i'm going to go from step
to step to step and time progresses in
this kind of linear fashion from one
step to the next but instead what i call
multi-computation where you have these
many threads of time many different
things can happen there's this whole
branching merging multi-way graph of
possible things that can happen with
many threads of history and and that's
kind of the thing that in our models
deals with accounts for quantum
mechanics and so on but it also is a
thing where you fundamentally have to
have an observer seeing what's happening
in the system it's not good enough to
just say what did the system do well it
did many things
well what did you notice as an observer
as an observer you are potentially sort
of noticing oh you only notice the
winning path or oh you only notice this
combination of bars that are sort of
within your horizon so to speak
so the observer becomes a very
fundamental part of the model
and in fact for observers who have
characteristics like us they're very
generic things you can say about models
like these and that's really interesting
stuff and that's what's led to this idea
of the ruliad and this sort of common
sub substructure for mathematics and
physics and so on but any case that that
fourth paradigm
i think has implications for a huge
bunch of areas of science in fact i i'm
even beginning to suspect that
you know i felt in the in the in the
1980s i felt that a lot of areas of
science were blocked by complexity they
were like oh they're all these
complicated things that are going on how
could we understand how could we have
any kind of theoretical framework for
that
and then along comes computation and
computational irreducibility now you
have a framework where complexity is
easy to get before that people have been
saying it's really hard to get
complexity we have to tweak things and
twiddle things and do all these kinds of
complicated things and then we'll get
complexity and that's a big triumph but
actually in this kind of computational
paradigm complexity is very cheap to get
it happens all over the place
now in this kind of fourth paradigm
there are some other phenomena which
actually go against complexity there's
complexity underneath but as an observer
you get to see certain computationally
reducible things those things end up
being like general relativity and like
quantum mechanics they are physical laws
that we humans can actually talk about
they're they're not sort of incredibly
irreducibly complex they're things that
are kind of uh
accessible to humans so to speak
and so
that i i have a suspicion that a bunch
of fields that have been sort of uh kind
of now ingested to some extent the
complexity idea they're sort of blocked
because there isn't a way to make a kind
of human narrative law from those fields
but in fact with this multi-computation
idea and this kind of fourth paradigm
idea it may be possible to do that and i
think for example biological evolution
is one area economics is another area
linguistics is another area but one that
i just wanted to mention is molecular
biology and chemistry
where
the sort of the big discovery of
molecular biology in the last century
has been the discovery of dna basically
that individual molecules can store huge
amounts of information
uh before that it was just like well
we've got these few chemical species and
they do what they do before it was as
well as this particular dna molecule and
it's got six billion base pairs in the
case of humans or well it's not one
molecule there but but um it's got you
know you can have a a billion long
molecule with with tons of digital
information in it and so the question is
what you know is there a different
paradigm for thinking about what's
happening in molecular biology my guess
is that this kind of fourth paradigm and
this idea of these kind of multi-way
graphs but in the end what that
translates into is it matters not just
what the molecules are and how many of
them there are but also the detailed
choreography of one molecule collides
with another which then goes off and
collides with another and there's a ring
of collisions and so on and what is the
detailed kind of causal structure of
what happens underneath and i'm i'm kind
of guessing that this will be one of
these things where people
afterwards said wait a minute why did
you know people were perfectly well able
they had all of the all of the
information to be able to see that you
could do something with this but they
just didn't do it and i suspect the
reason
not been done is that the formalism that
you need to understand this is kind of
complicated i mean
you know i think we're trying to make it
as simple as we can but to get to the
point where you can even understand
there's an issue it's at least the the
way that i've gotten to it is about 40
years of kind of sort of
science technology
understanding detail you know actual
things about computation understanding
things very theoretical things
understanding practical things that make
one care about the theoretical things
etc etc etc it's been a big tower to
build at the end of it it may be a lot
easier to explain but um you know i kind
of think that's an example of something
which is kind of a a there's a lot of
stuff in biology whether it's um a lot
of things to do with oh i don't know
pick one aging for example is a good
example uh that sort of an old person
like me starts to care a lot about
is um you know why does it happen what's
really going on is it a zillion
different effects or is it just some
sort of is there a fundamental paradigm
we don't understand about these kinds of
things
and i'm sort of suspecting that there
that there's a a fundamental sort of
paradigmatic change that one can make in
a field like that
um
all right i think i'm i'm uh
got to wrap up in a moment here
um
but uh
um
[Music]
the uh oh talking of of aging i see m
commenting that they're a cryogenic
engineer if you want your brain stored
later in life please don't hesitate to
contact
well uh
yep eventually eventually that's
probably something uh one um
uh one has to care about you know one of
the things that i think is is a another
piece of the kind of i can't believe
they didn't do that earlier type things
will be cryonics and i think it's just
like i remember asking for years
why was cloning impossible for mammals i
knew it was possible for lower organisms
and people would always give me these
stories about how oh the mammalian egg
cell is different and it's got this it's
got that and the thing is more
complicated and it can't possibly be
cloned and etc etc etc and then back
when was it in the early 90s you know
dolly the sheep came along
and um uh there it was a um
uh
uh you know a mammalian clone
um and i i kind of think that cryonics
um is something which again
people will say well why didn't you try
you know doing this thing with magnetic
fields and uh
you know why didn't you hack the water
molecule in this and that way to prevent
it from forming ice that destroys the
tissues and
so that you could just uh you know take
uh
you know do do what's been in science
fiction forever and ever and sort of put
people into suspended animation so to
speak um and uh um
and just you know hit the pause button
freeze out for a while and uh and and
reanimate so to speak that that that is
in a sense it's a physics problem it's a
problem actually the specific problem is
primarily that water
has a weird feature that expands when it
freezes and so if you take your average
one of us who's mostly made of water and
you make us very very cold then the you
know the water in in our crust in our
cells will expand and crystallize and
it'll blow the cells up just like it
does for you know your average kind of
food that gets stored at low
temperatures and we're also big enough
that you know if you just make us cold
on the outside it's hard to get the cold
into the interior
of of of us kind of quickly enough now
you know you can think about oh you
replace all the capillaries with
something cold and so on and people try
and do things with various kinds of
antifreeze and such like but my my guess
is that the the real problem is if you
could take water and make it go either
you put some kind of uh thing in it that
prevents it expanding when it freezes
that may be really difficult i don't
know
actually i do wonder hmm
like heavy water for example which which
won't perfectly operate our biological
processes but i i don't know what
happens i i assume that heavy water
expands when it freezes i don't know
good question um the uh yeah i assume it
does hmm yes i assume it does
so not a good idea but but um uh you
know and and um
but i think it's something where there's
sort of some physics
that
all has to do with water if you can get
water down to what is minus 44 degrees
centigrade or something then it forms
this non-crystalline material that
doesn't
isn't bigger than the liquid um but you
know how do you get from between zero
and minus 44 is a long way to get and
it's hard to get there um
the um
uh
uh sort of hard to get there without
having you know all the cells destroyed
in the process but anyway so if you
solve the problem let me know i i might
need to pause one day i have to say i
think okay i will i will riff on this
just for a moment and then i and i have
to go um actually i'm doing another live
stream part of my day job but but to
riff on this for a moment i mean it's a
it's a funny thing to imagine you know
let's say you could
go on pause
for 50 years 100 years
it's like uh
you know it's it's complicated enough i
i don't know for example i've
i grew up in england i've lived in the
us for more than 40 years now um what is
it 44 years or something now
and uh
occasionally i'll go back to england and
i'll be like this is really alien this
is not um
you know i i i thought i knew how things
worked here my children are super amused
you know i go into some store and i'll
i'll i'll shop as it's called in british
english and uh you know i'll i'll ask
for some kind of candy sweets in british
english um that or at least that was the
translation to british english who knows
maybe it's changed over the last 44
years i'm not sure and i'll ask for some
kind of candy where the person will look
at me like you got to be crazy i know
what the heck you're talking about um
because it just doesn't exist there
anymore but there are there are deeper
more cultural things that have changed
too but um i think that the um this is
one of these uh you know if you imagine
kind of you you pause out for 50 years
100 years whatever it is and then you're
back and the world is the way the world
has evolved after that period of time um
it's a it's an interesting thing to be
plopped back into and it's a thing where
one has to wonder
you know is it um
uh you know i think i i sort of get the
feeling that there are people who would
like to have lived at a different time
in history right now you know the people
who go and uh
go to the i don't know the you know the
renaissance fairs and do medieval
jousting and things like that that they
might have been real happy might not
have no idea but but um to be living in
the middle ages or whatever um and i
think uh it's sort of an interesting
question whether one you know one grows
up with a certain sort of cultural
background and a certain uh language one
speaks in a certain way of thinking
about things and it's a thing which
exists at this time in history and if
you if you kind of go and time travel to
the future um and you're 100 years later
you know what is it like at that point
and and um how do you uh uh
you know are you are you the last person
who who knows anything about um how
some uh antiquated piece of computer
equipment works and and you you know
your kind of main activity is being the
um
uh the person who remembers that weird
stuff from the ancient past when people
used to uh you know when people just
started doing live streaming and and
they weren't using you know augmented
reality and and this that and the other
and it wasn't um uh it wasn't you know
hg
communications and all that kind of
thing
anyway all right i better go and
go to my next thing which will also be
live streamed a
software design
uh
meeting
whose topic i do not know of hand but
anyway well lots of i saw lots of
interesting questions come in i look
forward to addressing them uh when i do
another one of these in a couple of
weeks
um
but
until then thanks for joining us